good afternoon before we start the
second quiz went up last night so you
can go ahead and take it the first one
is still up I think it's up to tomorrow
so try and keep up with them because I
want you to have to go back to your
notes and remind yourself what we talked
about each week and if you do you should
be able to get all the questions there
right from the slides that I give you so
today we're going to talk about virus
structure and there's a lovely quote
here from David Baltimore a virologist
is among the luckiest biologists because
he can see into his chosen pet down to
the details of all its molecules and
biologists are very fortunate and that
they have a lot of structures of viruses
and that is going to lead our discussion
today and I brought a few viruses with
me today which you've probably seen
these giant microbes right can buy these
things very smart company this happens
to be polio
and they always put eyes and mouths on
these things at least they make people
aware this is not bad in terms of the
structure as you will see it's
relatively correct but I have another
one here what if you can guess what this
is right HIV which is totally wrong this
is completely wrong
so we'll see by the end of today whether
you can see why it's got eyes - of
course they all have my eyes I don't
know why
so viruses are built to be functional
and beautiful as well and that's of
course the motto of the Bauhaus movement
to create something that functions
properly in essence has to be explored
it should serve its purpose to
perfection it should be durable
inexpensive and beautiful so all of that
applies to viruses they're cheap and X
and beautiful so the virion proteins
that make up virus particles have
several functions they protect the
genome so inside these virions or viral
genomes one of the main functions of the
capsid proteins is to protect those
genomes so after they have to form a
stable protective shell they have to
recognize the nucleic acids specifically
you don't want cellular nucleic acids
going in there and they in some viruses
that have membranes around them they
have to interact with those membranes
when the viruses infect the cell they
have to deliver the genome to the cell
they have to bind receptors as we'll see
next time they have to unquote they have
to open up in some way to release the
genome sometimes they have to induce
fusion with membranes if the virus has a
membrane around it that has to fuse with
the host cell membrane and the virus has
to move to the right place in the cell
and that's different depending on what
kind of virus it is could be the
cytoplasm it could be the nucleus and
the structural proteins are involved in
the transport to those sites other kinds
of interactions besides these with the
hosts throughout the infectious cycle
capsid proteins structural proteins
interact
other cell proteins so that replication
proceeds efficiently we'll talk about
some examples of that transport to sites
of assembly now we're talking about the
other side of the infectious cycle
everything has to assemble at the right
place and then once the viruses are
released in an animal for example it has
to interact with the immune system now
one thing that's very important to
realize is that viruses are not inert
structures they're not just particles
that are passively taken up by the cell
they are metastable structures and what
we mean by that I'm going to explore in
a couple of slides they have not
attained their minimum free energy
conformation minimum free energy
conformation for a virus is gained only
when an unfavorable energy barrier is
surmounted and that usually happens
during attachment and entry of the
particle the viruses go over this energy
barrier they attain their minimum free
energy conformation and they open up so
the state the particle itself is not the
minimum free energy conformation this
will become clear in a moment what I
want you to think about is that viruses
are actually machines molecular machines
that play active roles in the delivery
of the genome into the cell so let's
explore metastability a little bit it's
the ability of a non equilibrium state
to persist for a long time so viruses
are non equilibrium States or in a non
equilibrium state and they can persist
in that state for a very long time until
they reach the right trigger and
metastability is usually a consequence
of a very slow phase transformation so
you could keep a virus somewhere for
eons if you could eventually it would
reach its minimum free energy
conformation an example is diamonds at
room temperature they're metastable
because they transform very slowly to
graphite but if you heat them up we
increase the rate of this transformation
and the diamond goes to graphite so
viruses are the same way we have to give
them a way to go quickly through the
phase transformation and that occurs
during entry of the particles into cells
besides the viral capsid proteins which
are metastable
bonds and DNA and RNA and protein are
also metastable and again for viruses
this free energy state is gained when we
go over a high energy barrier during
attachment and entry so in other words
to be infectious the particle has to be
metastable it has to protect the genome
it has to be stable but it must also
come apart so it has to be both so we
call it metastable sort of a paradox but
it's accommodated by the physical
properties of the virion again the virus
is a molecular machine it has moving
parts and it does work as you will see
and we'll see later when we talk about
assembly viruses are actually
spring-loaded to unquote the genome but
they do so only under the right signals
they don't want to release the genome
when they're floating around and in the
atmosphere or in your digestive tract
they want to release the genome upon the
proper signal and that's the same signal
that gets the virion over this energy
barrier so when we assemble vo yawns we
put energy into the structure and when
we uncoated energy is used for
disassembly so there again they're
active containers they're not passive in
some cases actually replication and
transcription of the genome occurs
within the particle we'll see some
examples of that some many viruses open
up and the genome comes out but some the
replication takes place within it so
they are actually containers for the
whole process and often the capsid does
not completely come apart I don't you
get the idea that one of these viruses
gets into a cell and all the pieces fall
off and the virion RNA or DNA is left
there many of them just openings come
apart and let the genome out for example
retroviruses the RNA is converted to DNA
inside the particle and we'll see what
for real viruses double-stranded RNA
virus is the replication and mRNA
synthesis takes place inside the v
around so just ajust examples of how the
virus particles can also be containers
for there's different stages in
replication so we're going to talk about
the structure of the virion
today the structure of the
article which is created by the
symmetrical arrangement of very
identical proteins to provide maximal
contact and non covalent bonding so this
is very important symmetry and non
covalent bonding non covalent C allows
you to take apart the very ons to let
the genome out the particle has to
deliver the genome so that's one of its
other function structure is to maintain
the genome and then to deliver it into
cells and this is made possible because
we don't have covalent bonds holding all
the proteins together so this is an
amazing accomplishment to make a
particle like these without covalent
bonds and that's done by taking one or a
few proteins and repeating them and
having those proteins interact really
well with one another okay so some
definitions to make sure you understand
some of the words that I'll be using the
subunit I'll say is a single folded
folded polypeptide chain so I'll say the
provirus is made up of subunits and all
I talk about there are the single
proteins sometimes I'll talk about a
structural unit which is an assembly
it's the unit from which captions or
nucleo capsid ZAR built one or more
subunits so one or more proteins now the
capsid Latin for box is the protein
shell surrounding the genome so this
gray poliovirus here this is a capsid
within it is nucleic acid a nucleo
capsid is the core now the nucleo capsid
is within HIV this is supposed to have a
membrane around it but this is showing
an icosahedral capsid as you'll see in a
moment so the nuclear capsid is the core
that Cane's contains nucleic acid it's
typically protein mixed with nucleic
acid envelope is another name for the
viral membrane and that's derived from
the host cell host derive lipid bilayer
the virion of course is the infectious
viral particle when I say virus I'm
using it as a generic term virion means
a very specific thing this is a virion
but only if it's infectious if it's not
infectious which many viruses are it's
not a virion
infectivity is inherent in the
definition so to put the size into
perspective again we we touched on a
little bit of this earlier a nanometer
of course is ten to the minus ninth
meters so atoms are about point 2 to
point 3 nanometers in diameter and alpha
helix and a protein about a nanometer in
diameter DNA to a ribosome 20 and
poliovirus 30 you remember we showed a a
drawing of ribosomes next the polio
similar sizes and they'll very large me
me viruses 750 nanometers here's some
more size comparisons this is an
illustration of proteins that are in the
protein data bank and these are based on
three-dimensional structures here you
can see a rhinovirus about the same size
as polio which is the gray virus sitting
up there and these are all other
proteins that you would find in a Cell
of various sorts various enzymes here's
trypsin for example synthetase and so
forth so you can see viruses are
slightly starting look slightly larger
than most cell proteins and get very
very much larger so first we'll start
with this very important experiment from
1955 at UC Berkeley the first
deconstruction and reconstitution of a
virion what they did was to take tobacco
mosaic virus which is this rod-shaped
virus here and they they broke it into
its protein and RNA components remember
that was the first virus discovered it
was also the first one from crystals of
which crystals were made and the first
one that to be shown that RNA makes
genetic monistic material when they took
the protein in the RNA that they had
separated and mixed them together virus
particles formed spontaneously and those
virus particles were infectious so this
is showing that all the information to
assemble the particle is in those two
components now the structures that we're
going to talk about today we're
determined by a couple of techniques and
these are the tools of viral structural
biology that are used today these are
described in some detail
Chapter three electron microscopy x-ray
crystallography crystallography
cryo-electron microscopy and nuclear
magnetic resonance spectroscopy we'll go
over some of these so what we know about
the structure of irises really began in
1940 when Hellmuth Ruska used an
electron microscope to take the first
pictures of virus particles and there's
the the article in German which reported
that finding and electron microscopy
depends on getting contrast into
biological materials which inherently
have little contrast if you've worked
with any kind of cell you know or or
tissue sections you know there's very
little contrast in that so they have to
be stained but they can't use just any
stain to be examined by electron
microscopy you have to use an electron
dense material because after all you're
bombarding the specimen with electrons
and it will pass through most things
except stains that are refractory to it
these are some stains uranyl acetate
phosphate on state that will scatter
electrons when the electrons hit the
stage so you stain with those materials
the resolution is not very good so the
the smallest structures you can see an
electron micrographs are about fifty to
seventy-five angstroms and just by
contrast an alpha helix of a protein is
10 angstroms in diameter so you cannot
see individual protein chains obviously
so no detailed structural interpretation
is possible and so typically there are
two ways you can stain viruses on the
left is shown one way by putting the
stain covering the entire particle so
you put the viruses on a grid shown in
orange you put the stain on top which is
this gray material and then the the
electron microscope bombard it with
x-rays and wherever there is a electron
dense material the x-rays don't get
through the electrons don't get through
and this is a kind of image that you can
pick up by doing that so when you do
this you stay in the background and
which gives detail to the particle so
this stain is molding around the
particle and it's staining it's making
it outline
the particle but when you cover the
particle with stain you get both the top
and the bottom at the same time of the
particle so you have a mixed image and
and that is often making it difficult to
distinguish fine structures so typically
what's done is to only bring the stain
up about half way as shown here you get
only one part of the particle and that
gives you more accurate
structural information and just to show
you the difference when you cover the
particle with saying you get this kind
of image which probably looks perfectly
good to you but when you only cover half
the particle you doesn't begin to
resolve these sub structures these
doughnut shape sub structures which are
very important and you don't see those
in the other because of the two sides of
the virion are stained so here are some
very nice images of viruses we'll just
turn the light off for a moment so you
can appreciate them these are all
electron micrographs negatively stained
viruses herpes virus up here hepatitis B
virus the famous picture of adenovirus
the capsid is here and you can see these
antennae if you will coming out
influenza virus
apik or no virus and you can see here
some of these are empty they're broken
they've lost their nucleic acid so
there's the stain doesn't pass through
them and a pox virus here so very very
nice pictures and these you can imagine
when this was first done people
immediately saw what viruses looked like
they'd never known that before all they
knew was that there was something that
could pass through a filter and infect
various organisms so that's electron
microscopy
now you take a variant of electron
microscopy and you can do very high much
higher resolution structural studies and
that's cryo-electron microscopy which
will give you resolution between 8 and
20 angstroms in fact now it's getting
even lower in some hands what you do
here is you take a preparation of virus
particles here's an electron micrograph
and you don't stain them you just freeze
them and the freeze them gives them just
enough freezing gives them just enough
contrast that you can see them in the
electron microscope and then you take
pictures of the individual particles the
assumption here is that every particle
is oriented slightly differently on the
grid so it
basically like doing a cat scan of a
person where you rotate the x-ray
machine around them and get multiple
slices you're doing the same thing you
take a few hundred pictures of viruses
and you digitize the images and then you
use Fourier transformations to convert
the images into phases and then you you
you mix them all together so here we're
showing one two three
different slices but in effect you would
have hundreds of slices and then you do
an inverse transformation to make the
particle from that so you're basically
taking slices of virus images and very
in many different orientations and using
software to reconstruct the entire
virion so that's why this is called
3-dimensional reconstruction because
you're reconstructing it from a
two-dimensional image so that's
cryo-electron microscopy this is the
kind of image you can make with that
technique this is poliovirus okay the
same virus on grey up here in the desk
it's now shown in red and this pulled in
this case the virus was mixed with its
cellular receptor a soluble form of the
receptor that is without the cell and
those are in green and so you can see
very nicely you can resolve the virus
particle as well as the individual
receptors binding to the surface of the
virus now the highest resolution comes
from x-ray crystallography in this
technique you have to make a crystal you
have to take your purified virus and
find conditions under which it forms a
very nice crystal a lattice of molecules
you bombard the crystal with x-rays and
then you'd make an image of the scatter
of the x-rays on in the old days that
was done on film now it's done on an
image sensor and the idea is that as you
bombard this with x-rays the x-rays
bounce off different atoms in the
crystal and end up on the scanner and
they are a representation of the crystal
lattice and so you turned the crystal in
various orientations and bombard it and
eventually you can deduce the
three-dimensional structure by by phase
transformations similar to what was done
for cryo a.m. the resolution here as
much greater can be less than two
angstrom
in many cases so the the genesis of
structure biology began in 1935 when
Stanley crystallized tobacco mosaic
virus Oh another first with that virus
he just made crystals and he showed that
if you dissolve the crystals then the
virus was still infectious so that meant
it was being crystallized in some
biologically relevant form and for that
he got the Nobel Prize in 1946 but that
wasn't the first virus to whose
structure was determined unfortunately
it was this one tomato bushy stunt virus
TBS V this was solved by x-ray
crystallography
in 1978 and it's not really red of
course but I suppose they took some
license from the name this is a plant
virus it infects Tomatoes the first
animal virus to whose structure was
determined as poliovirus these are two
different images showing you the
resolution of x-ray crystallography on
the upper left you can see all the
individual amino acid chains and
cryo-electron microscopy this is about
eight angstroms so you can't see
individual chains but you can see the
overall morphology of the particle now
how do you build viruses symmetry is the
key and this comes from the work of
Watson and Crick which you may remember
were two individuals who proposed
destroy the original structure for DNA
they also had a big role in our
understanding of how virions are built
so in 1956 they said they published a
paper saying most of the virus particles
that we've looked at under electron
microscopy by that time where either
spherical or rod shape you didn't see
anything else and they also knew that
particles were made with many copies of
a few proteins so up to that point some
biochemistry had been done on virus
particles and for the most part there
were just a few proteins and they seemed
to be repeated over and over to make the
variants
they also deduced that viral proteins
have properties that allow regular and
repetitive interactions among them this
is very important
this is not something we find in the in
the world around us except in viruses
that you have proteins that are built
that can repeat with one another over
and over in the same way so their
contribution to virology was the
conclusion that identical protein
subunits are distributed in the virions
with either helical symmetry for
rod-shaped viruses or platonic polyhedra
symmetry for round viruses so a
rod-shaped virus is like tobacco mosaic
virus the long rod shape these are round
viruses okay that's what they meant by
that that was their contribution there
are two general ways to build virus
particles this is pretty much correct
even today there are some variations on
these themes but they were they were
quite right it's as important as was the
discovery of DNA I think so the symmetry
rules provide the rules for
self-assembly of particles and here they
are rule one each subunit member subunit
is a protein each subunit has identical
bonding contacts with its neighbors this
isn't quite correct but it's close
enough for this for this point in the
story the repeated interaction of
complementary surfaces at subunit
interface naturally leads to a symmetric
arrangement so again the proteins the
subunits of a virus are repeated they
interact with each other in very similar
ways that gives you a symmetrical
arrangement rule to the bonding contacts
are usually non covalent and again
that's important because you have to
take these particles apart if these very
ons were made of covalent we linked
proteins they would never get apart upon
infection the reversible formation of
non covalent bonds between properly
folded subunits leads naturally to ever
free assembly and minimizes the free
energy so regular structures form when
identical bonds are made between
identical sub utage take a protein it
will illustrate this in a number of ways
if you make identical bonds among the
subunits you get a regular structure and
that's unusual because if you make non
identical bonds between different
proteins you get aggregates or clumps or
disordered complexes
and that is the the unique aspect of
virus assembly so we have repetitive
interactions among a limited number of
proteins that gives you a regular
structure and in fact if you express
just the capsid proteins of a number of
viruses they will self assemble into
capsids
you could take some viruses there is one
protein that you can express and it will
make a virus particle and a great
example are the vaccines for hepatitis B
virus and human papilloma virus these
are made by expressing one or a few
proteins of the virus in yeast or
another cell systems for the papilloma
vaccines it's just one protein it's
expressed and they make particles and
these are shown here in the electron
microwave micrograph so all the
information needed to make a particle is
in the primary sequence of the protein
and you get repetitive interactions
between the proteins and they form a
capsid now just on this past week in our
podcast wit we got a letter from Sheldon
in Toronto and he says please explain
how virus-like particles are created for
Gardasil and Cervarix and beat those
being developed for flu vaccines it
seems somehow magical that you can build
something that is structurally a virus
on the outside but is essentially an
empty shell
so he's absolutely right it's magic
because it's in the nature of the
protein so I just wanted you to see that
there are people out there wondering how
this works now you know because the
proteins have this ability to interact
with one another in symmetrical ways
that's why you can get these virus-like
particles so let's explore the two types
of symmetry
the first is helical symmetry it is the
way tobacco mosaic virus is built and
also a number of viruses that infect
people and what happens here is that we
have a coat protein and these engage in
very similar interactions with one
another and also with the viral RNA
which is shown here in yellow sorry in
green alright so each of these is the
coat protein subunit the tobacco mosaic
virus is just made of one protein it's
repeated over and over and it forms this
helical structure
okay and so that is that is the virus
itself the protein in the RNA doesn't
have anything else associated with it
these are some examples of animal
viruses that have helical symmetry
this is sendai virus the nucleo capsid
so we call this the nucleo capsid now
because it is part of a bigger structure
this is usually surrounded by an
envelope in animal viruses and this is
vesicular stomatitis virus or rabies
virus they both look like this same kind
of symmetry a coat protein wrapped
around in a helix with the nucleic acid
and here is tobacco mosaic virus so
that's the virus particle just this this
rod like structure composed of the
protein in the RNA and this is vesicular
stomatitis virus the helical nucleo
capsid is in here and it's wrapped with
a envelope this is not really a very
good depiction of this okay it's not
really a coil it is a very tight
structure that looks just like that and
this is sendai virus these are the
nucleo capsids that's this guy this long
rod right here and they are encased in
an envelope and this one is broken so
the nuclear capsids are spilling out but
you can see how they would normally be
contained within the envelope now you
can make your own demonstration of the
helical symmetry with these buckyballs
so you can buy okay you can go in fact
saul silverstein gave me these a year
ago and I said I can build a virus from
this that's what I want to show you so
these are very strong magnets did not
know actually okay so this is helical
symmetry okay and each of these magnets
is a protein subunit it interacts with
each of its neighbors in an identical
way and it makes the capsid of that
virus that was on the screen before so
the RNA is attached to this you don't
have RNA here but you can see there's a
there's a helical rise here so it's just
the way a virus is built perfect I
didn't take me a year I was I had these
on my desk and one of my students was
playing with it and she assembled it
into a long strand and I said I'll bet
you could make that into a helical
nucleo capsid and here we go so I've
been waiting to show you this for about
a year ok so that's pretty cool those
are bucky balls I have a movie here for
the people who are gonna watch online
who aren't here so they can see it as
well
it's it's basically me doing the same
thing wrapping up this this chain of
bucky balls and making a virus out of it
now the interesting question yes so each
subunit also binds the nucleic acid yes
now that's a good question because if I
took all these magnets and threw them in
a cup they wouldn't form a helix they
need the RNA to do that the nucleic acid
because that drives their assembly into
this kind of structure so this is not a
perfect example of what helical symmetry
is because there's no RNA involved but
you get the idea basically ok that's it
I gotta put that on YouTube see now see
how many hits it gets yes yeah yeah
now they deliver the gene encoding the
protein into a cell either a yeast cell
or an insect cell and the gene is
transit is transcribed to mRNA it's
translated into protein within the cell
and then the proteins self assemble so
you could take the purified protein in a
tube and it would also self assemble
most likely but for production purposes
for making a vaccine you need a lot of
quantity they express it in cells okay
yes yes
so the the virus-like particles that we
talked about are made by symmetric there
are there icosahedral structures I don't
know of any where a helical structure
has been made with just the protein it's
my understanding that you need the
nucleic acid to nucleate two helix all
right is there another one okay yes well
in these helical structures they are yes
but in the capsids to submit these
icosahedral capsids that we'll talk
about next we don't know because we
assume there are some interactions but
we haven't been able to visualize them
structurally because the RNA or the DNA
is not ordered inside the capsid so it's
hard to see the interactions it's making
but when you solve the structure of
these helical nucleo capsid you can see
the nucleic acid interacting with the
protein because it's given order by the
protein order okay so this is just an
example of this interaction so here is
here's a virion of vesicular stomatitis
virus the nucleo capsid the the helical
nucleo capsid is within a membrane so
again here's the same image I showed you
before which isn't quite right cuz it's
not a coil this should be much tighter
now and this is made up of RNA plus the
N protein nucleo capsid protein it's a
single protein shown the structure is
shown here and here
is is an image of nine of those and
there's a green molecule sneaking
through it which is the RNA so you can
see the structure of how the RNA
interacts with the protein so this is
actually data from x-ray crystallography
so you can here on the right you can see
1n subunit and nine nucleotides of RNA
how they bind it and when you put many
of those together they form a helix okay
so the interaction of the protein in the
RNA is shown here for most for all the
animal viruses I know of that have
helical symmetry they all have envelopes
none of them are naked like tobacco
virus okay I don't know why that is it
may be related to the way these viruses
are transmitted in nature so here are
just some examples of envelope virions
of RNA viruses these are negative strand
rnas with helical capsids measles virus
para mix of your D rhabdo rabies virus
influenza viruses have this helical
structure ebola and for all of these the
capsids are always called nucleo capsid
z' because they're within a membrane
envelope again the nucleo capsid the
nucleic acid protein assembly that is
packaged within the virion the nucleo
capsid is not the virion for these
viruses for tobacco mosaic virus we call
it the capsid because that's it there's
nothing else okay
that's not really so important just I'm
telling you this so you don't get
confused in the future all right now
moving on to round viruses remember
these are the round viruses these guys
like this how do you make a round capsid
from proteins with their regular shapes
now the magnets are not really
instructive because they're all the same
shape and in fact these proteins are
asymmetrical the ones that form these
helical nuclear capsids are asymmetrical
but again it's it still illustrates the
principle but even harder is how to make
a round capsid from these different
proteins
well first clue is that all round
capsids have precise numbers of proteins
always and they're usually multiples of
60 although that can be that can vary
but for the most part they're multiples
of 60 60 180 249 60 etc so that gives us
one clue next next sirico virus has come
in many sizes but capsid proteins are
usually between 20 and 60,000 Dalton's
and size so you can get very big capsids
remember Mimi virus is 750 nanometers
but the proteins aren't that big so
somehow the two have to come together
alright so Casper include two structural
biologists in 1960 to solve this issue
they knew from Watson and Crick that
round capsids are also like casa
hedron's
so they remember I told you originally
they were a platonic solid but in fact
there are many platonic solids and only
one is ever used to build viruses and
that's the icosahedron none of the other
ones they also observed that capsid
subunits tend to be arranged as in
groups of six in groups of five hexamers
and Penta MERS and that the number of
capsid subunits in the virions
followed allowable and values of T
numbers we're gonna talk about T number
in a moment 60 180 240 960 and nothing
in between all right so those those were
the facts they started with and they
said icosahedral symmetry turns out to
be the most economical way to build a
symmetric shell with maximum internal
volume using non symmetric proteins okay
of all the platonic solids this is the
best one that fits all the bill
symmetric shell maximal internal volume
because you want to put a genome in
there and using proteins that are not
spheres but they're asymmetrical that's
the icosahedron cathedra of course is a
solid with 20 faces each an equilateral
triangle has 12 vertices and what are
called axes of rotational symmetry
that'll be more obvious in the picture
in a moment this allows the formation of
a closed shell with the smallest number
of subunits so that's the smallest shell
you could make one of 60 subunits can't
make anything smaller we don't know any
virus that's has fewer than 60 subunits
we do know viruses with more I'll show
you how to build those as well but an
icosahedron allows you to do this
because of the geometry so here's a
drawing of an icosahedron
remember it has 20 faces and 12 vertices
and 5 3 2 axes of rotational symmetry so
20 faces this is a face these are the
vertices and these are the axes of
symmetry a five-fold a three-fold and a
two-fold axis and all that simply me
is that there are five copies of a
subunit around it so five fold access
this one there 12 faces around it if
this is if these are made of one protein
that would be five proteins around the
fivefold axis same for the threefold and
twofold they're mostly used for
reference points so sometimes I'll point
out a virus picture and I'll say the
receptor binds around the fivefold axis
I just want you to know what I'm talking
about that's with reference to this so
here are a few other views of these
threefold looking down at the threefold
axis it's the same as that we're looking
now down at the fivefold axis so one two
three four five subunits around it and
here's the twofold axis there are two
subunits so here is a drawing of a
simple icosahedral capsid it's made of
sixty subunits remember that's the
smallest virion we can make using this
symmetry the protein subunit is shown as
a comma here is the structural unit and
all these interactions the interactions
of all these commas again each comma is
a single protein there's sixty of these
in the virus particle their interactions
are all the same in the particles so
every protein interacts with its
neighbor in the same way head to head
tail to tail alright so here's the
fivefold icosahedron axis you can see
one two three four five copies of the
protein around it
twofold icosahedral axis one two copies
threefold one two three
now you also see there are some areas
where there are six one two three four
five six copies so in some of these in
some of the viruses you do have six fold
interactions as well so that's the
simplest capsid you could build sixty
subunits they proteins are asymmetrical
and that's the point of drawing it as a
comma you have the head and the tail but
they all interact with each other in
very similar ways so here's an example
of such a virus a parvo virus the kind
of virus that can infect your dog or cat
it is a it is a very small capsid 25
nanometers in diameter it's made of 60
copies of a single capsid protein one
protein repeated 60 times it's an
asymmetrical protein but it can interact
and
very similarly throughout the caption
and that's what the protein looks like
here and that's the virion so for
example these different parts of this
capsid protein are colored so the blue
part here you can see forms the fivefold
axis of symmetry it's very easy to find
it you can just look at the point where
there are five repeated subunits around
it one two three four five so all the
blue is contributed from five different
proteins and it's this specific part of
the protein so how do you make a bigger
virus so you have sixty copies of a
single protein you how do you make
bigger viruses you just add more
subunits very simple and this relates to
the triangulation number T T is simply
the number of facets per triangular face
of an icosahedron so here's a triangular
face has one facet but you can take that
triangular face and insert three
additional facets into it it gets bigger
this is still the triangular face but
now we have facets in it and that's
achieved just by adding more proteins to
it and if you want to make bigger
viruses and we know that they exist
we're trying to explain how they are
made you simply add facets by adding
proteins so this is called a T equals
one virus and this is called the T
equals four viruses and any captured
with a greater than T equal one T number
will have a six-fold axis of symmetry so
I misspoke in the previous slide that T
equals one particle does not have a
six-fold axis has all fivefold threefold
and twofold but this is now a T equals
four virus you can see one two three
four five six in addition to three two
and fivefold axes so simply putting in
more proteins to make a bigger virus now
gives you not only Penta MERS or
fivefold axes but also six-fold axes as
well okay the T number simply refers to
the number of facets per triangular face
here we have one two three four facets
the T number is four here we have one
facet in the triangular face the T
number is one so you'll see T number in
the
and other materials that you read they
just want you to understand what we're
talking about you can use the T number
to calculate the total number of
subunits in a virion so it's 60 times
toas and again the simplest virus is T
equals 160 subunits one virus particle
so for example a T equals three at
icosahedron has 180 subunits 60 times
three and this is in sets of three T
equals four 240
now not all viruses follow this T rule
60 T and I you don't need to really
understand why but on this table are
some examples of that here for example
this simple parvo virus the T the number
of subunits or 60 T is actually 60 and
that's what we observe but you can see
that for simian virus 4060 T is 420 but
they're only 360 copies of one of the
proteins so not all the rules follow but
they're pretty good overall well you
have to know is that some viruses do not
contain 60 T subunits and you don't have
to know why now when we put more virus
sorry when we put more proteins in a
capsid to make a bigger particle to go
from this to something much bigger you
get more than 60 subunits we increase
the T number now we encounter something
called quasi equivalents remember when
we had a small virus with 60 subunits
all the subunits all the proteins
interacted with each other in identical
ways when you start putting more
proteins in to make bigger capsid that
can't happen anymore they're pretty
similar but not exactly the same so we
call them quasi equivalent okay that's
all that that means when you put more
than 60 proteins in a particle they each
subunit or each protein occupies a quasi
equivalent position what that means is
that the non-covalent binding properties
they're always non-covalent of subunits
in different structural environments are
similar but not identical so only in the
T equals 160 case are they are the
interactions all identical anything
bigger they're not so the
an example of 80 equals three now we've
put in extra sub units to make the
capsid bigger now we have three modes of
sub unit packing we have orange modes
orange modes here we have yellow molds
and we have purple modes of packing we
have both Penta MERS and hexamers now
the hexamer is something you get
remember when you add more than sixty
protein subunits and the bonding into
interactions are quasi equivalent all of
these proteins engage in tail to tail
and head to head but they're slightly
different depending on where they are in
the particle so that's all that quasi
equivalents means is that the
interactions are not quite identical and
that's a consequence of trying to make a
bigger particle so this T equals three
viruses bigger than the T equals one
that we first started looking at so
here's an example of a T equals three
virus it's called no de Muro virus this
is a virus that infects insects it's
made up of 180 copies of a single capsid
protein and in this image on the lower
left you can see the various rotational
axes here's a six-fold axis and here's a
fivefold axis as well fivefold axis of
symmetry six-fold again the six-fold
arises because you're putting in more
proteins it's as simple as that now
poliovirus is an example of a T equals
three caps it as well it's made up of
actually four capsid proteins but the
fourth one is simply an extension of one
of them so in an in reality it is a
equals three virus and it's called
pseudo T equals three because you
actually have four capsid proteins again
you have fivefold axes of symmetry here
are five copies of VP one surrounding
the fivefold axis and there are there
are six-fold axes as well
now what's shown here is is to give you
an idea of how you actually build a
shell from these proteins all these
proteins that form capsids actually have
have volume of course and that's
diagrammed here so these this is all the
polio virus capsid proteins can make a
wedge like structure when they're folded
properly and these wedges simply packed
to form the virion so the thickness of
the wedge gives you the thickness of the
virion itself and they make a very nice
closed shell because there are wedges
and they interact non-covalently and I
think on the next slide we have a
illustration of how that happens so
here's a surface view of poliovirus
here's your fivefold axis of symmetry
you can see the star up there here's a
six-fold axis and again this is T equals
3 so you have to have six-fold axes and
here's a cross section of the virion so
you can see this this is the thickness
of the shell which encloses the interior
the RNA would be in here and that
thickness is formed by those wedges the
proteins are wedges that pack together
to form this shell now in all of the
this is a structure determined by x-ray
crystallography and all the structures
we don't see the nucleic acid that's
because it's disordered in the interior
in order to get crystal structures you
the proteins have to form an ordered
array and the nucleic acid doesn't do
that so that's why we don't know how the
nucleic acid is interacting with the
capsid for a few viruses there are a few
nucleotides visible in the crystal
structure and that gives you a little
clue about how the RNA is interacting
with the protein but for the most part
we don't understand how they are packed
in now there are even bigger viruses
that we can see that are built these are
called structurally complex they do have
for the most part by Casa he drill
symmetry but they are much larger than
this and they have many more components
so they all follow icosahedral symmetry
but they have other proteins inserted as
well that have specialized functions so
here's an example of adenovirus is not
something you would ever have to
remember I'm just showing you this as an
illustration these are all the various
proteins that are present in the capsid
of AD no viruses so you have hexans and
penton's
which form the icosahedral capsid but
everything else for additional proteins
that have specialized functions for
example there's a fiber protein if you
remember a few slides ago I showed you
an electron micrograph of adenovirus and
I said there these antennas
sticking out those are the fibers and
those are what are used to attach to
cell receptors so there are 12 of those
because there's one for each fivefold
axis of the acosta hydrant and there's a
variety of other proteins as well both
in the capsid shell and inside binding
the DNA so that's what we mean by
proteins devoted to specialized roles
not just building the shell but they
have other functions as well and here is
an example so this is adenovirus here's
the icosahedral shell and the hexans and
penton's are the look that the major
proteins that comprise the shell then
they're the fiber proteins that emanate
from each fivefold axis again
axis again those attach to the cell
receptors but then you see these little
proteins in between these these brown
ones here and green ones underneath
these have other functions some of them
are thought to glue the capsid proteins
together to help them stick together of
course they're not glue they're just non
covalently bonded but for some large
capsids it's believed that other
proteins have to stabilize it in the
middle of the virion there's the nucleic
acid and that's also bound to proteins
as well so these are very large
particles now 150 nanometers going up
from 20 to 30 the smallest ones these
are T equals 25 now so 25 times 60 would
be the right T number and their fibers
at 12 vertices this is the structure of
some of the components of this virus
particle here is the the capsid you can
see the nice icosahedral symmetry
here's a fivefold axis of symmetry from
which the fiber emanates it's gone in
this image and these are also hex ons
which are surrounded by six different
hex ons so here the Penton is surrounded
by five hex ons the exons are surrounded
by six this is just a structure of the
fiber that emanates from the fivefold
vertices so again illustrating this idea
that you have in addition to proteins
that build the shell a lot of other
proteins in these big viruses that have
other functions binding to receptors
protecting the nucleic acid gluing the
capsid together and so forth
there are some very interesting viruses
that actually consists of two
icosahedral shells concentric li
arranged and that's the real viruses
these are T equals three pro viruses
they have two concentric shells one of
them 70 nanometers and one of ninety so
just imagine an icosahedron shell we've
just built several of them and they're
simply 2:1 around each other and that's
very unusual now in some cases those
capsids the virus is just the capsid so
this is poliovirus this is my casa he'd
rule capsid one two three four five I
can count fivefold axis of symmetry and
there no six-fold axes on here I don't
know if they couldn't do it or they
didn't know but there should be some
six-fold okay anyway this is the virus
of polio that's it
for some though the capsid is covered by
a membrane all right
covers this thing and that membrane is
very common does these membranes are
very common in viruses particularly
those that infect animal there are very
few envelope plant viruses we don't know
why it's derived from the host cell
because the virus can't make its own
lipid doesn't have any machinery to do
that so all envelope viruses derive the
lipid from the host cell it can be
acquired by budding through a cellular
membrane and it could be almost every
membrane in the cell can be nuclear
membrane can be a plasma membrane but it
always virus specific so the influenza
virus is always bud from the plasma
membrane and the herpes virus is bud
from the nuclear membrane
it can also be other membranes in the
cell as well the nucleocapsid is in the
envelope can have helical aurica
icosahedral symmetry okay so remember
the helical symmetry this kind of
symmetry this can be wrapped in an
envelope and for animal viruses it
always is but for plant viruses it's not
and then we can have these icosahedral
particles also wrapped in envelopes so
that gives you other options for
structure as well so in if you wrap a
virus in an envelope so take this and
you wrap it in an envelope if you just
use them
membrane from the hotel there's nothing
specific about that membrane you have to
give it viral property so old virus has
put proteins in that membrane derived
from the hotel these are called viral
envelope glycoproteins so the envelope
is the membrane surrounding the virus
the viruses put their own glycoproteins
and these are integral membrane
glycoproteins that means there's a part
of the protein on the exterior of the
virus here's the viral membrane there's
a transmembrane segment and typically
some protein sequence in the interior of
the virus as well
these have a variety of functions in
replication they're used for attachment
they are used to generate antibodies
when you make antibodies against these
viruses typically these are the proteins
that antibodies are directed against and
also when these viruses fuse with the
host cells we'll see next time
these proteins play an important role
and they're often oligomeric which makes
in they're originally called spikes so
when the first electron micrographs of
these viruses were done here's influenza
virus they were saya these look like
spikes on the surface so that's what the
name has stuck in since then but they
are each individual viral glycoproteins
now the viral glycoproteins can be
perpendicular to the membrane as shown
here on the left for the H a the
hemagglutinin of influenza virus that's
very typical but other viruses Flavie
viruses West Nile virus the glycoprotein
is horizontal it's lying down on the
membrane both both ways work just two
distinct topologies so here's how these
horizontal membrane glycoproteins look
from the top and from the side and
here's how they would be on an intact
virion so you see the virion surface has
these glycoproteins lying down you might
notice here that there is some symmetry
here right doesn't this look like a
five-fold axis of symmetry well it turns
out that some of these this this
particular virus ISM has a membrane
around an icosahedral shell and the
icosahedral symmetry of
the show is being transmitted to the
glycoproteins on top we're gonna talk
about that now
so these viral proteins these
glycoproteins interact in at least three
ways with the virion on the left is an
example where the glycoprotein is going
through the virus membrane and it's
interacting with this capsid or nucleo
capsid this would be more accurately
called a nucleocapsid because it's
wrapped in a membrane but you can see
the the end parts of the viral
glycoprotein are interacting with the
capsid protein so that's one typical
arrangement you can see if that's the
case then the symmetry of the nucleo
capsid should be transmitted to the
glycoproteins on the surface okay so if
this glycoprotein is interacting with
one of the five proteins around the
fivefold axis then the glycoprotein will
also assume fivefold axis of symmetry
that's what was happening in the
previous slide sometimes there's an
additional protein below the membrane of
the virus it's called a matrix or an EM
protein it's in blue here and that
contacts the capsid and in turn it also
contacts the viral glycoprotein or you
can have some viruses have multi protein
layers where there's more than two
layers between the glycoprotein and the
capsid of the virus just different ways
to build particles now here's the
structure of us of a toga virus it's a
positive sense RNA virus single strand
it's called Simba's virus and this is an
example of how the symmetry of the
capsid is transmitted to the
glycoprotein so this is an envelope
virus has glycoproteins in the envelope
within the envelope is an icosahedral
shell the glycoproteins contact the
shell directly so here is a
cross-section of a single virus particle
this is actually an amazing structure
this is the RNA in the center on the
outside of the glycoproteins and here
you can see the lipid bilayer the two
leaflets of the membrane the
glycoproteins are passing through the
leaflet the bilayer and they are
contacting the capsid so here the capsid
proteins here surrounding the RNA
and the glycoproteins are contacting the
capsid proteins directly as a
consequence if you look at the outside
of the virus particle which is shown
here
you see five three and twofold axes of
symmetry in terms of the glycoprotein
arrangement right the icosahedral capsid
is on the inside but because it
interacts with the member with the viral
glycoproteins in this manner the
glycoproteins assume the symmetry of the
underlying capsid so that's called the
structured envelope viruses because the
capsid underneath gives symmetry to the
glycoproteins
on top many viruses are unstructured
many envelope viruses are unstructured
and here are three examples vesicular
stomatitis virus again it's an envelope
virus around a helical nucleo capsid
there is no there's no icosahedral
symmetry here this is helical symmetry
but there aren't contacts between the
nucleo capsid and the glycoproteins such
that they would trance new clear capsid
would transmit any sort of regularity to
the viral glycoproteins same with
influenza virus it consists of helical
nucleo capsid surrounded by an envelope
but these are not contacted by the viral
glycoproteins same with retroviruses so
unstructured virus or unstructured
envelopes there's no contact between the
interior and the exterior glycoproteins
that would give the surface any kind of
regularity
now herpes viruses are examples of very
large viruses that are built on the
principles of icosahedron symmetry but
which have also additional viral
proteins like adenoviruses and I find
these amazing because these are two
thousand angstrom Furion's over half of
the viral genetic information is devoted
to building this capsid so the virus has
eighty genes and over 40 of them encode
structural components so that's a lot of
genetic cost to make this shell so to
make a big virus is not cheap in terms
of genetics so there are 13 envelope
glycoproteins and two distinct internal
structures there's a new
there's an icosahedral nucleo capsid
that surrounds the DNA this is made up
of four different proteins so this is an
AI typical icosahedron as a T number we
know the number of subunits of it
it also has what's called a tag ument
made of twenty different viral proteins
which is surrounding the nucleocapsid
and it's involved in protein delivering
proteins required early in infection mmm
so here is an image of herpes virus
solved by cryo-electron microscopy
here's the intact virion here on the
left the yellow or the glycoproteins on
the surface of the virion and in the
interior we have the icosahedral capsid
that's in the light blue here and then
the orange is the segment the blue is
the membrane the orange is the tagamet
so you can see that it's a typical
nucleo capsid icosahedral nucleo capsid
but has these other structures as well
now in addition to this the icosahedral
cell has a very interesting feature
which is it has what's called a portal
and i think we'll turn the lights out to
see this portal you can see the portal
here in this electron micrograph it's
right there right there and that's what
it looks like there's one portal per
virion and that portal is used to get
the DNA in and out of the particle so
it's built of one at one of the 12
fivefold vertices of the capsid so the
fivefold vertices are in red and one of
those is devoted to being a portal and
that's how we think here's the portal
here at one of the fivefold axes you see
there's a hole there none of the other
fivefold axes have that hole and we
think that the DNA goes in and out of it
so another example of a specialized
structure built on top of icosahedral
symmetry what else is invariance besides
all these proteins we've talked about
there are enzymes of various sorts some
viruses have to bring enzymes into the
cell to replicate the genome you'll see
in the retroviruses there are integrase
is so that the genome can be integrated
into the host cell enzymes to cut
proteins of various sorts enzymes to
make poly a tails to put caps on mRNAs
to unwind double-stranded DNA other
proteins are needed for the synthesis of
mRNA transcription or other parts of the
replicative cycle and even cellular
components some viruses package histones
tRNAs there's also lipids of various
sorts and all sorts of molecules in
virions besides the structural proteins
that we've talked about I just want to
show you two examples of this
this is poliovirus and this is the
structural subunit of the virus which
consists of three proteins three
different proteins blue yellow and red
the fourth is an extension of the yellow
protein that's why it's pseudo t equals
360 of these or may are assembled to
make the virion and you this is the
final variant on the bottom which we've
seen before this molecule and white is a
lipid it's sphingosine a long-chain
lipid which in which there is one per
subunit so since there are 60 subunits
there are 60 copies of this lipid in the
final structure and you can see some of
those here around the fivefold axis of
symmetry so the fivefold axis is built
right here and these lipids surround the
fivefold axis we think these lipids have
a role in entry of the virus into the
cell we will talk about that next time
in influenza virus is another
interesting protein aside from all the
structural proteins in the virion that
is the m2 protein so here is influenza
virus it's an envelope virus surrounding
the RNA genome there are glycoproteins
integral membrane glycoproteins in the
membrane of the virus but there is also
a very minor protein one of between 4
and 16 per virion called m2 and it's
shown here it's embedded in the lipid
bilayer this is actually an ion channel
and this has a role in entry of the
virus into the cell as we'll see you
next time
so they get another example of a
specialized viral protein it doesn't
have a structural role but serve some
other function in the viral life cycle
now bacteria phages follow these rules
of symmetry as well this is an example
of one of the tailed bacteria phages the
very famous ones you see in early images
of viruses in some of the earliest ones
study so the structure of this tailed
virus was determined by x-ray
crystallography and cryo-electron
microscopy you can see the head is built
with the rules of icosahedral symmetry
this is a perfect icosahedron it has a T
number it's built with certain numbers
of proteins that interact in quasi
equivalent ways but you can see it also
has some other components as well so the
nucleic acid is stored up here in this
head but it also has a neck the
contractile tail and it has fibers that
it uses to attach to the bacterium and
finally a base plate through which the
DNA is injected so when this phage sits
down on a host cell it pokes a hole into
the membrane uses enzyme using enzymes
that are found in the base plate and the
DNA is injected through the tail at high
pressure but these are all components
that are added to the icosahedron L
which serve specific functions just like
the portal of herpes virus and the glue
proteins of adenovirus and finally this
is the latest structure of Mimi virus
which is this huge virus that we've
talked about it's 750 nanometers in
diameter it is the biggest virus we know
if it has a 1.2 million base pair DNA
genome and the T number is 1179 remember
the T number times 60 gives you the
number of protein subunits in the virya
these are huge and I'm amazed that
actually they were able to derive a cryo
electron micrographs structure of this
virion and here it is right here you can
see it's built just like an icon
Sahid Rijn it's just really big in the
middle this white material is believed
to be the genome now you can see it
doesn't have any order to it but it does
have a density and there's this very
interesting star which is completely a
symmetric it's only on one side of the
virions none of the other sides have
this star and the hypothesis is that
this is what actually opens up when the
nucleic acid gets out of the particle so
these blue lines represents areas in the
capsid that can come apart and let the
DNA out and because they show up
differently on the cryo-em that's why
they're colored blue here the
interactions must be different amongst
those proteins then amongst all the
other proteins and the rest of the
capsid so another example of how you can
have very specialized regions of even an
icosahedron shell that allows you to do
specialized functions so I the title of
this is complex structures are
challenging viral structural biologists
so this is not easy to do because it's
not only technically difficult to get
the images but the computational
processes that are involved to solve the
structures are are quite large and
that's another example of how biology is
attracting more people who are
interested in computational aspects of
structure
you